I mean the property investment circle  and this is the place to be you should  be the property circle because there's  no stuff to learn you can buy houses  we've no money down and you should  because terrific you should circle if  you wish to network get yourself known  and just to get the atmosphere is quite  cynical when I first attended as I'm a  chartered wealth manager and I've been  really pleasantly surprised with his  professional approach to matters and  most importantly about the positive  returns on investment that are available  through proper professional property  investors so thanks Sam of course  following up with you very shortly